okay I want to keep you updated about
the coinbase hack that led to us losing
thousands of dollars a couple days ago I
came to you and explained that
from events stemming from coin based
support asking me to publicly send them
my support ticket number a series of
events took place which led to the David
Pakman show
losing thousands of dollars that had
been paid in not by art this has nothing
to do with membership or patreon but
from some of our advertisers and
cryptocurrency contributors our account
on coin base was immediately locked up
pending investigation and the question
of whether we will be compensated has
been an open question yesterday we were
waiting all day to hear back from
coinbase about what is going on and when
I followed up yesterday with coinbase I
was told we've not received any
information from you about what happened
I believed that the last 24 hours were
coined as coin based working our case
and was notified yesterday that they
haven't received nothing from me despite
my repeated emails supplying the
information they asked for clearly some
kind of problem with their support
ticket system I resent the information
multiple times and presumably they've
now received it because and the reason I
mentioned this is that if you go and
look at the official coin base support
Twitter account now they have
immediately stopped asking people to
publicly send them support ticket
numbers and every request from coin
based support now asks for the private
direct messaging of people's support
ticket numbers this is exactly the
security vulnerability that led to the
hack that lost us thousands of dollars
so what what I see Pat when I see them
having done that is in some way they're
recognizing that I was right that asking
for that publicly was wrong because
within 24 hours of it happening to us or
rather more like 36 or 48 hours
they've immediately changed their policy
to one where they asked for a direct
message I hope I hope that that means
they recognize that their actions were
at least partially responsible for the
loss we suffered and that this means
that we will eventually be at least
partially if not fully compensated for
the loss I don't know that but hopefully
that's an auspicious sign sounds like
they're working on the case at least to
some degree yeah right they wouldn't
have changed that policy if they still
hadn't received my information I think
we're just gonna have to wait through
the weekend we'll probably know more by
Monday about this I hope so because the
the problem is that not only have we
lost the thousands of dollars in the
hack the money that wasn't taken is
beyond our reach at this point and our
ability to continue receiving payments
we can restore receive payments on that
account but we can't see whether we've
received those payments and that's
really a problem for our ability to
continue conducting business and it's a
real big problem one other thing I want
to mention I mentioned yesterday that
there have been some GoFundMe and other
crowdfunding campaigns popping up
claiming to be raising money for the
david pakman show as a result of the
coinbase hack and i mentioned yesterday
we're not running any of these okay and
I don't know if people are in good faith
trying to raise money for us if so we
hadn't been notified or whether they are
trying to collect money on our behalf
which then they are going to keep in any
case these continue to pop up at least
two of them have been shut down but once
again I'm stating if you want to help
don't create a campaign that sort of
purports to be representing the David
Pakman show because they are getting
shut down and if you actually just want
to help its membership in patreon right
we don't want anybody pat trend up
contributing to a campaign that is not
actually a campaign associated with us
so email me if you see any campaign
saying we're raising money to help the
David Pakman show because of the
coinbase hack it's not through GoFundMe
if you want to help it's through patreon
or a membership at join pakman.com